you
you
[Music]
what's up everybody has it going happy
Tuesday all that good stuff
Persia here today max is joining me
because we're playing some apex legends
and of course we always bring max on
yeah I'm glad to be here really looking
forward to the next two weeks yes
exactly so if you guys don't know what's
going on with apex legends for the next
two weeks the grand soiree arcade event
is officially live starting today it's
so fresh that max is still downloading
the update as we speak so yeah for those
of you in the chat also asking when is
it live when it's hat when is it but
when is it happening it's happening
right now so yeah go and update at least
on the PlayStation because that's what
we're playing on today mine is
downloaded and ready to go which is this
is my screen right here but we're not
gonna be watching my horrible gameplay
although max does have to carry me today
we're going to be watching max but yeah
so just just so you guys didn't see what
it's looking like before max's finishes
up he's at about 81 percent right now so
we will be in a match very very soon
everyone in the chat oh yeah I actually
didn't finish explaining the events so
here we go this is the first event of
the two weeks every two days the game
modes are switching so there's seven
game modes in total whew it's a lot it's
a lot and if you guys remember like
after they have that one apex like
developer episode and they were like no
one's found the Easter eggs yet oh yeah
and then they kind of found the Easter
eggs which was like the dummy thing yeah
and then they found another Easter Egg
which was the third person thing which
ended up being two games is slightly
tested to make sure that it works before
yeah which is more exactly exactly so
yeah
today we're playing the gold rush duo's
it says grab a partner and survive in
the first limited time mode of the grand
soiree with gold weapons only available
to play January 14th and 15th we'll have
new modes rotating every two days until
the event ends on the 28th so make sure
you come back to see what other fun
modes we have to offer they're all him
that's what they really are you know I'm
excited though in this mode I'm actually
excited to pick up a Mozambique in Appy
2020 right off the bat I'm happy with
dropping and getting some good weapons
for once yeah Sam so they also have of
course as always some special costumes
and event exclusive items I love this
finders his mustache guy I know
I love it I love it even down to this
suit yeah amazing I definitely don't
have this much points unfortunately
there's also some other ones this one's
pretty cool too this one gives me some
zilean vibes from Lee legends just a
little bit rocks so so the whole point
of this all this this theme right here
is that the roaring 20s which is a
hundred year event right it's 20 20 1920
s so this is kind of cool homage to that
time period which is just mind-blowing
and they didn't even say that directly
but like people are talking about it
they're like oh yeah it's been a hundred
years since this kind of style came out
so t-rex in the chat says Bangalore skin
please well here you go
Gia's looking fierce good looking fierce
I'm so happy today she got finally got a
good skin cuz like some skins
I mean her like original scans are
really good but then like every single
deal see you skin or like event skin
she's kind of like funky I actually
really liked the day of the dead one
that she had actually yeah I liked that
one but this one it's pretty this one's
pretty dope
it's like retro soldier mixed with like
modern day I don't even know but if I'm
going into battle and I look like that
I'm hey good like clothing wise two four
four battles I think it's not too much
clutter so it might be easier to high
Beus pretty funny that they named it
that dad that's pretty hard this is the
only one that's like obviously not
twenty yeah
got the band-aid on his abdomen area
but yeah just taking a look at some of
these skins this one's nice too I like
that color combo yeah hello Brandon
hello everybody in the chat how's it
going bloodhound pleased yes here you go
here you go yeah he looks pretty good
oh snap do you guys hear that that means
Max's game finally updated before we
move on just want to show off this other
legendary scan for a Spitfire it's
pretty cool that is pretty cool
it definitely has the muzzle like a
retro vibe to it like a trumpet right
these right here like when you play the
music notes this right here and then
McFly this is yeah yeah for sure that's
cool yeah and this one I think goes with
obviously Kryptos but yeah I like how
kryptos costume is says taejun park
around his collar which is like trying
to like not sure that I know his name
big bold letters on his jacket that's
pretty silly
I even like his hair in this one yeah
actually sir pretty cool alright so now
that max have finally joined me in the
grand soiree
we're loaded up I think it's time your
your game oh I almost joined oops wait
no don't accept that I'm coming with you
all right there we go
cool all right so we took a look at the
skins we're officially loaded up and
ready Gold Rush duos is live Lauren help
us Lauren helped me max will be but I've
been up and down on the apex these days
it's been some pretty good day so
there's been some really rough I mean if
you like that yeah I feel like more I
should have played more like right after
Christmas you know the whole like
Christmas noob stereotype thing probably
what it did really well everyone was
like on day one apex yeah it's all good
kind of picking up again ever since they
kind of nerf Pathfinder I've been soul
searching for like who I really really
like ah I used to mean her I just feel
like it gets so sweaty that her stuff
becomes not as useful to me like her old
and everything all right so gold rush do
is you want to drop far do you want to
drop
let's go let's go in between yeah that's
the first game at least all the weapons
will be gold yeah so I'm assuming
there's gonna be like no attachments or
anything laying around since everything
is couple squads dropping down more in
the inner-city operations
I am excited giggles okay
okay I'm done with this you know I like
this it should be like this all the time
oh yeah so all the gold guns are just
gonna be around like even the stuff that
would normally be oh I found a creeper
Oh am I feeling froggy yes I am
we might want to camp up someone like a
large rifle okay okay Thank You Richie
missing us good luck I'm gonna need it
especially if I'm going for some creeper
shots
whoa Oh someone you want to help me a
snipe this guy as it comes off yeah I'm
just not in a good spot I'm gonna try to
move closer oh boy all right
Oh actually you know body probably yeah
we're just so blinded by having gold
weapons that is your only white shield I
mean maybe a creeper wasn't a good idea
[Music]
yeah someone is going in just here I'm
popping off this is hi lovely tune in
for me running around with a creeper on
ground level hell yeah oh oh I see
somebody oh my gosh no but I forgot how
cool cravers owns a long time to reload
though yep
I'm terrified I feel like we're hyper
focusing on the city and no one's come
from behind us yet yeah you know what
I'm kind of just go in I mean it's gonna
be going on for a while
closing in someone that's targeting me I
got voices in my head
I love rates passive okay so there's
gold box over there oh well I guess
every box is gonna be gold definitely
only white shield still though yeah I'm
not seeing that many well I really want
to go for that little box but I don't
know if somebody's gonna be targeting me
two masters or is that one Mastiff show
all I know is I got Milton was that oh
my god sounded like it was on turbo okay
alright so I definitely think we need to
drop hot okay yeah we have gold weapons
anyways yeah exactly yeah I'm not really
scared about dropping hard cuz I every
single time I drop hard it's always a
crappy one yeah there's a Mozambique or
no weapon but at least we'll get some
good ones who else is mad about wreathes
nerf what did they nerf about her oh
yeah please tell me some other Wraith
man know what I'm like are you thinking
about a new one or oh wait I forgot okay
but yeah man I really wanted to use that
Craver yeah Scott likes such a slow
bullet - yeah it's really slow it's got
tons of drop that the get your ultra
matte considering they buff Gibby I mean
yeah I don't know I kind of like his
buff if he's been pretty good
he's been on the constant up and up for
like
I think he only got nerfed like twice
that's because they over bucked him says
the wall the original one was his
ultimate last yeah things like he'll fat
takes less time to use your equipment in
items yeah yeah bubble shield 35 seconds
on cooldown and one more speed bonus
with old
oh really
[Music]
what okay I'm the jumpmaster we're gonna
go in there wow that really sucks
I might actually drop race for that cuz
like that's the whole point is exactly
that combo
[Music]
[Music]
so second I ran in there and I'm tired
picking up guns I was like oh no this is
not gonna end well I kind of don't want
to respawn here yeah maybe I the next
ring a little too spicy
oh crap right in the face we're good
yeah we dropped super high Ritchie was
okay because max he's got this
kind of don't know where to pick you
back up it's fine
just okay I'm gonna run yeah you'll
you'll eventually come across a respawn
point somewhere trains here too which
means people are going to be around in
this area I want at least have a chance
you know if I'm going to respawn you
over there he's just gonna be madness
they put more respawn beacons
this one's been here like that other one
was really close all right cool
we back that that was all a part of the
plan actually
[Music]
I was like looking at your screen to see
what was available okay all right can
you see me you think I'll crawl over
here I heard him chasing me too I was
like dang this this feels like hardcore
mode there is weapons that I feel like
we just have to go ffensive as much as
possible you're right so I think like a
European situation cuz I barely find me
aren't we I know I spent total like 40
seconds on the ground that entire game
it's gonna be a little bit of this guys
it this is what happens in apex he's
just getting a loop and then like every
like 7th or 8th game like okay let's do
I know but you just have to go through
like the works for a while I think once
we find a good place Lin get some good
guns well they're all good maybe you
know find them first I think if we go to
my regular area the geyser it's like
it's good sight lines it funnels people
into really small holes which I like
because I don't like being attacked by a
random direction
I'm going with octane this time because
I just want to be on the move although I
need to test out a race ultimate and
then alright check that and I see that
it's really bad I'm probably gonna go
back to life only sad because that was
like the whole guys got to be some
balance master this time alright this is
the one I'm gonna check it out over
there this is the one right here are you
guys don't you worry dropping in hang on
oh man the guys is real close - so it's
like but no we're not
okay new one all right okay okay I've
got a gun Oh shoddy snipers that's how
we're rolling today Mastiff there's
somebody on the other side of your
building oh no 95 right here that was
messed up I hit her point blank with the
Mastiff and it only did 9500 yeah she's
leaving yeah I thought she ran too cuz I
heard looting and then I heard nothing
okay dang Wow okay oh wait I want to see
wait how much dough you did 95 yeah I
did I did five less doesn't thin enough
to kill her rip me it was messed up to
Iran in that room and I was like Oh a
mastiff and as I was like picking it up
she came through the door got killed by
three or four mass I mean the Mastiff is
beast yeah what up Alex welcome to the
stream we are trying out Gold Rush duo's
it's a little intense so far yeah just
saying but it's all good it's gonna take
some trial and error
yeah there's I like that swatch though I
feel like yeah
than you I'm down to go back there that
grenade should have hit her so spoke and
yeah right I was like yeah yeah I don't
know super unlucky that's alright
do you have to update the game yes you
do already
alright keep going back there till we
win yeah exactly it's nearby
[Music]
might be clear really
yeah oh yeah
I literally picked up the same exact
loadout I died with last game the guys
always make me think someone's dropping
hear me yeah that sounded really
annoying there sounds like there's
somebody flying overhead all right well
I guess there's nobody around yeah I
barely had any loot right there yeah oh
[Music]
so it looks like the name I think is it
only shoddy snipers after like them no
let's not write a flatline earlier yes L
star stuff is rifle cravers everywhere
they're like none of you guys can aim
here I take all these creepers take all
these sweaty twitch
three triplet eights and then Scout
noise there's a purple shield out
towards the other direction there might
be bot that has key no bald shell toe
worth noting oh let's do it just go ham
I was hoping for some action when we
landed through I don't go too far ahead
cuz I'm not yeah I'm just peeking out
the door oh I see a death box oh no just
kidding that's a first aid kit
all right next mission find a cargo
button and open that vault so we can get
something better than white armor no so
hard to get good weapons in this game
type or a good armor in the same time L
stars and like cravers are pretty good
for your inventory because they don't
need ammo directly from the inventory
yeah I have one I really do okay that's
like the first thing I picked up a
sniper right I have a scallop okay I
don't sniper right now let's just go
towards the city that's right here's
some let's make a spy see some action
yeah and why I mean action I literally
mean like one bullet I heard one bullet
fire and that was it I heard it too fine
means he's shooting at somebody
all right these guys I don't have a
ranged weapon so oh I see him he's up
there cuz I took forever to throw
grenades
[Music]
there's somebody else looking at us too
right there oh he's already down we
confirm Aguila thank you I know I here
am I here oh I was ready to hide away
for him to run around that was a
different guy I think so yeah was
somebody else do I try to be sneaky
boiled yeah boils again man it reminds
me of you know like the Train Express
mode or it's like you never really get
good healing items either syringes once
you get down you're like alright you
spin like a minute and a half straight
healing myself or do I just don't you
know what I'm a bad lifeline I should
have dropped a bomb I'm sorry
that was my fault but yeah alright I'm
gonna be a better yes Richie F for
foiled it was foiled I mean their
account smart with the jump traps cuz if
you do do it like they did what happens
is if you
don't jump into the room like you're
stuck in there mmm so I wouldn't have
been able to get out that's why I didn't
go in there all right
you know I feel like I'm learning I'm
learning some things here it'll take a
second masta for sure that's a necessity
nothing hurt I'm still undecided so far
I really only see in like a flatline a
scout trip will take creepers
there's a lot of snipers that I'm not
working and they get like gold are a 301
or oh I'm the gem master
where's our little oasis oh it's over
there that's okay
we are playing on ps4 Jorge asks George
I don't want to go there's someone there
all right well it's uh let's get dad
along this way shoddy snipers yeah I'm
not sure but I'm think the g-seven got
nerfed like you're sniffing everything I
ain't they yeah if anybody knows exactly
what the nerf was let me know line the
same oh nice I feel like it's so rare
now Wow blue helmet gotta win a fight I
know okay like someone's in you all
right I'm gonna take a look in this
direction
does massive use regular shotgun ammo
once you're out your own yes it's just
special okay so it doesn't consider your
inventory yay I found a blue armor nice
yeah I'm feeling better about this
around you guys
oh yeah crypto they're down there let's
go attack
I'm the worst I literally miss point
Klingons
oh my god I should have stayed up top I
got thirsty I was like you know what I'm
just gonna run down there I was actually
shot said in agony grenades I missed
every app for my aim that was I don't
eat that badly I swear that was like we
had the right idea we're almost actually
like rushing them down we just didn't
have the execution yeah although that's
weird I feel like three or four grenades
yeah my grenades are just ignorant the
range of grenades because I was like
three or four grenades on a line last
area yeah they didn't get touched all
right
hmm what up Killian said hey dudes right
back at ya happy Tuesday show the store
we showed some of the store items at the
beginning of the stream if you want to
tune back into the intro to check that
out we show it again later
oh I'm John Master hurry go to the
special place I'm just a little salty
from that last night I'm going in
streaming nerves are really bad I'm
usually not that bad I swear
I didn't check to see if anyone else
[Music]
happens quick be ready Oh double Mastiff
nah there's massive in here there's
people over on that side though they
want to chase them or wait for them like
I'm over here
um okay I should come towards you then
oh no they're over there okay all right
I'm gonna come back towards you but I'm
going the back way
Karimi I was like I'm gonna be sneaky
and meet up with you around this way ten
minutes later squads down yeah they're
the only ones okay right yeah I swear
guys I'm not that bad
I mean I'm not like amazing or anything
but that last match was like I kind of
maybe just a touch painful hey it'd be
like that's some time you're just like
what is going on yeah yeah oh we're
close to the ring a bulky yeah I know
because we just get that nice armor
like I haven't seen many cargo box yet
people been here okay yeah they probably
went off somewhere but I definitely have
not seen any SMG so far that's true in
less than lstart ounces SMG a well then
I seen an all-star no it's actually
considered a heavy weapon I think yeah
there's no or 301 there's no or 99 but I
think it's it's a seasonal gold thing so
I remember the last season there was
gold ore Nana mines and they changed it
over here behind us feeling as sure
they're like we're trying to sneak up on
us yo oh hold up hold up I didn't say
was wrong with me
[Music]
it's second I saw those guys like dang
this is a bad spot
[Music]
okay so Mastiff is like the game yeah
yeah I mean there's enough of him around
I think yeah it was weird because there
was a no audio cue for them climbing up
on us
they were pretty far I just happened to
turn around and like see them on the
roof behind us I was like oh crap
because you just ping someone on the
other side no lighting
yeah because soon as I saw one person
and you saw that guy
all right
play ship
I'll just go through a whole bunch of
character so keep it interesting for you
guys yeah Mario so sorry to watch the
start to play all right let me one-up
you they're also really bad yeah
oh okay only weapons that have gold
barians makes sense
why are we going to the party yep
now I thought they would just like make
every weapon of a gold version and then
everyone just party Auto oh oh oh oh I
knew chasing that wreath was not gonna
be a good idea yeah
dang it well I got that pathfinder at
least he was running around the craver
though so I was a little confident I was
gonna be able to take him out first
I mean I wouldn't have hit a noscope
Craver exactly I think you had a mastiff
- they did put out a schedule if you
guys want to know which game modes are
coming up each two days I think I want
to definitely play on nighttime night -
you can yeah I'm looking forward to
get down
octane I can run fast
all right they're not gonna be able to
catch us max we're just gonna run so
fast I'm gonna dodge all the bullets oh
my one kill was octene was that
Pathfinder last game let's go never play
dog team I just unlocked him recently
actually I was just using a lot of like
Pathfinder and breathe alright so yeah
hey thanks Pathfinder home last game
giving me that one killed my octane
let's go hold on tight it's time to drop
shock and rock Hey
look around survey the area sweats are
out right now we've got like two or
three spots dropping in the lava pit
oh one setting to us right now actually
crap crap I see a cargo like I've never
near you and you're like oh no Natalie
whopping 14 damage Oh someone's sniping
us
I don't know where you went
but someone else was sniping us though
oh I see him oh I got him for like 62
damage but there's a octane and a read
all that scared me
oh I got his s nice he was crouching
underneath this vine did he die yeah I
killed them probably also hiding heads
up rings closing in one he had an Ulster
here I know I don't want to stay still
at all like hardcore mode he like he
really does abandon his homie like I
think you did oh he's right there
got him hey we did it nice we got a
squad let's go I was terrified I'm just
not a sniper guy at all it's like it's
armed and dangerous definitely wasn't on
your list no I'll just run around with
I'll call it a shot East I'll just
forget about snipers somebody's been
there before I feel like the scouts the
least sniper a sniper yeah yeah it's
like a DMR yeah
I refuse to finally take down a team and
then die to the ring on some stupid nose
like that yeah which always happens oh I
see a wraith tunnel over there yeah
I feel like a hero movement that's me
okay it's not like it was in the tunnel
or something yeah we should get out of
the ring I am scared right here okay
okay yeah I was like I feel like there's
people in there okay I downed one
there's one of thoughts he's right
behind he's driving down right behind
you
I should just went around now I didn't I
was like I wish I did I was okay I
should have went around but I was too
impatient for that I was like if I run
around his teammates and come after me
it's fine
I guess he kills a game um I'm pretty
satisfied too more than the average
count actually so we've seen a lot of
pretty much every character I've seen
Wraith Gibby yeah I wonder though yet
that's true crypto has been kind of on
the down turn out for a while now
actually like when that character first
came out he was really popular and then
seemed like once every 10 G's he's kind
of hard to use I feel like yeah like
very stationary like I have to like you
said drone followed you like within a
certain affinity while you're running
around I was like that might be a little
better he'll be a lot cooler you just
need to like a little bit more
we don't be I need ideas like if the
drone would like walk on to you I mean
it can also follow you around too but
like yeah like set us somewhere and they
can like follow you so then anybody
around you would be excited right I'll
be kind of a cool idea and then if you
wanted to make it go further away then
obviously yeah that might make blood
hound a little yeah I think I think he's
like probably one of the coolest
characters like character lives but then
gameplay wise I'm like he's so hard to
use crypto yeah I'm trying to think I'm
ready
Dayna
we're warming up I'm feeling I'm feeling
better if I can land in there yes like
this there's no gun in here how dare you
guys
[Music]
this is rough this is really bad
everybody's got gold weapon we have
nothing I have what I found I found
weapons actually know what I'm strapped
[Music]
I need to run off I'll come back when I
have a weapon
okay I'm gonna ditch this popsicle stand
if blessed I will find loot here he says
that's like the most accurate thing I've
ever hear do you wanna want one of mine
I even and a triple deke okay
anything whatever you don't like here
you say you don't like snipers ilallah
teamwork all right
now where to
there's no purpose in the vault room all
right there weren't any gold ones in
there that's required that's half the
battle right there yep oh snap from Blue
Shield thank the Lord I was blessed yes
and the events already started it's
gonna be going on every two days well
it's going on for two weeks but it's
changing every two days
right now it's gold rush duo's all the
weapons gold and it's just duo's are all
the gold weapons are in the game yeah
I was hyped for no reason I was like
everything I thought like even like you
know gold shields yeah actually you know
that would have been very annoying to
fight people with
all right now well I got 60 off of
Pathfinder but his buddy showed us your
healing up I hear is that yours no it's
not mine well that's not even
[Music]
hold a face mask this baby let's go oh
please don't slay me right now I'm just
gonna bloom no I just got paranoid -
that's what I do I'm like gunshots could
be coming from anywhere right now
no things always get me because
nothing's moving stuff for the banner
capital city because that's where the
ring is
I had 17 shield cells whoa what what
yeah I got 20 shields not to Mastiff
boys second is cheap it's like why hold
any other shotgun yeah probably because
you run out and you know I digress boom
we're still alive let's go don't let me
commentators curse myself yeah exactly
hell this guy go I know he's reviving
his friend he's low thank you okay Laura
do you the struggle for me right now is
so real it's okay though that's two
squads down no max we are moving on up
in the world I hope so so this has been
like what six or seven games now and
that's the first purple body shield I've
seen dang that's crazy
you might have gone up on vault I feel
like that's the only way to get yeah cuz
I did to you someone earlier break a car
go by and one just that's what I kind of
hate about bloodhounds things like not
recently been here like I've waited hang
that differently enemies have kind of
been here five squads left max want to
play a safe where do you want to go for
it you know me
I'm him
you can go towards the center of the
Ring and defend it go across the tip
line how's a regular package well here
let me be the bait fresh Mastiff don't
mind if I do
yeah they were just right here can you
told its directness coming from it
sounds like it's in that direct oh yeah
I just saw someone throws something onto
the train tracks
I got nervous just looking out of doors
I'm like a creeper shots might just end
my life I kind of wish we had raised the
passive for that because that's really
useful to know when you're oh yeah you
being aimed at all the voices in my head
oh I see one okay okay Oh should we push
in we've got four spots left so that's
two of them right there in us and then
one more after that I'm just gonna take
some potshots here and there oh that for
me or that for somebody else
I'm just watching right now oh okay
someone shooting Oh behind yeah I think
he's up top okay are they coming for you
all right they camping no come and grab
me oh no he's grappling off my area
lovely all right
can't always coming through the door
right here my hands were sweaty that
game
lesson learned going for a while and
also reinforcing the fact that I hates
my procedure ding hey using snipers in
the heating smoke feel that was a sweaty
one yeah that was fun though you last a
long time we had what was that top five
I think
top five squats I feel like because this
is the second time dealers come out of
it yes like I feel like the first time
is like just more action-packed I feel
like there's a lot of like dead time
yeah a little bit because like the
fights are shorter because it's just
like cause like a weapons yeah instantly
but I just feel like these fights are
very few and far between
Thanks chat Sanket GG to us
we tried that was that was the best one
so far though thank you thank you I am
liking octane so I'm stuck with him
that was my fault my saga I was a little
far away from you dang we got that guy
good though the one that came in the
first one because I hid behind your
shield yeah protect you because I could
do it that was always good I shoulda
stayed like there gambit was winding up
my next massive shot people say whining
I've always think of them like doing the
arm oh yeah all right all right you guys
protip get a mastiff and don't let it go
yep that's sober I've been the only gun
to really save my life oh I heard
someone land with this alright double
charge rifle why not let's do it okay so
just a very triple-t level one you see
you see all these good things about the
mask that they're like all right no
masses for you
he's on a Blue Shield early yeah lucky
all right that's kind of nothing here
gold helmet really oh yeah you can use
that awesome
all right we're just guys that just go
ham well I do see a gold the gold shield
in the bolts and it doesn't matter gonna
get fined cargo but yeah where is that
thing because I'm the ring is not in
their direction anyways
really trying to 600 there's one down
here and then there's one watch out for
the new kill leader friend I feel like
we're gonna get partied if we keep doing
this though
yeah I'm just throwing some warning
shots but ultimately I'm out of here the
ring not too far though Oh somebody's
coming in on
[Music]
I have a bounce pass oh I do this wrong
spot I think yeah your name Oh God
nice
[Music]
so bad I hate that scope it's it goes
too far another two times really really
bad it's the two times scope I strafe
too much for this game but it's also
making me miss Alicia yeah that's why I
like the lead controller so much or like
the any scuff controllers you can focus
more on your aim when you're not like
taking your thumb up constantly oh that
was fun yeah that's good fight I mean
besides the fact that I got I didn't
actually want to drop down but I was
like it's too late I think that's why I
like this game cuz like I'm not
necessarily good at it but for some
reason it's just fun anyways yeah
meanwhile if I were to be losing like
this and like a halo Rakata yeah heck no
I mean as long as I'd like if I had a
good flight then I'm like okay whatever
it's like if I just get down and like
some really dumb way I'm like I know I
know Bishop I was looking for a mastiff
really really hard that's my favorite
gun so far in this mode it's so good but
I didn't get lucky and after and I only
had six like shotgun bullets left so I
was like I don't have enough yeah for
this fight I ain't dropping in
I saw the Christmas menu theme music oh
really
Thank You Ven thanks for tuning in have
a good one happy Tuesday oh yeah
hey that sounds like an optimal low down
right there I think
first blood
if you guys want to see a certain
character or if you guys want to see the
store are there any questions noon yeah
day one of gold rush duo's we're trying
our best
yeah I will say I feel like we're
getting progressively a little better
[Music]
big battle rial just make me constantly
scared and paranoid the whole time yeah
like there's always someone although I
guess if it I can squad your duo's and I
feel a lot better but so little battle
right but like Wraith is like a warm
blanket for me cuz I just know it okay
like at that point when I got likes
nights in ahead last time is Pathfinder
I would have known that
yeah we're being aimed at yeah you like
the paranoia freak actually one minute
rings not far definitely are punishing
me for being so hey it's fine it's fair
I get it yeah big you see the new
character skins are definitely available
and Alberto you're welcome posted ring
our pleasure to strange some of this
Moodle within for you guys even though
we uh are struggling
10 seconds to the ring it's close at
least don't see or hear anyone this is
yeah these long you seem kind of good
well not the lobby but like just the
spacing of where people drop it should
have had like three here gunfire but it
sounds far seven somewhere people have
been hearing gunshots yeah I'm running
towards it even though that might not be
the best spicy these guys right here
footsteps oh no oh that's close yes
he has a gold shield the one I just
signed on has a gold use oh nice
wow that was like oh wait someone else
is rare I thought that was your shot oh
that was you okay whoa did you pick up
that gold shield oh we don't really need
it all right hold up I need to regain my
composure here what do I need
I'm just there's too much happening in
here probably I got gold
I feel like I should give to you cuz I
feel like I'm going down first oh now
we're good we're good
you're trying to be stealthy and I'm
just like sure just look at the map dang
yeah the other two bolts are done zone
so okay dropping that key yep oh oh no
nevermind that is a tree I was like I
see someone yeah there's a couple of
bushes in this map that look like people
they're shaped like people
aiming-down-sights they're legit
all-purpose we go I'm gonna attempt to
find some heavy ammo
okay down in this pit that has no height
advantage whatsoever well I got a portal
to get us out energy
got to always be on them someone just
dropped in near us somewhere I see
someone on top of Miraj okay but I kind
of do I need more ammo oh nevermind yeah
girl found a mastiff alright yeah yeah
no longer needed all right where do you
think would be the best way to get up
there because I feel like the highway
might be a little obvious
yeah but also the way we might not
where's the map ending up yeah I don't
like the Mirage my gosh let's let's not
go that way hey just wrote a back open
like this
let's not go in the more Mirage side
let's go around this side noted we got
to be tactical you guys trying to at
least sort of win one or at least get up
there it's a very slow game though it's
been 10 squad all nine squalors now for
good forever people any people are
shooting on this
man I should have been unlocked Achtung
I feel like you definitely fits my style
very run gonna gonna go
you can bunnyhop with this okay okay we
got action now someone's on top of the
Sowers there's someone out in the field
over there and they're shooting out
swear it's like north west side so
someone just dropped a package I don't
know if I should I swear if we get
flanked my salt is gonna be super real
trying to hang a little bag to try to
pick up audio but oh yeah I'm fine
around firing at someone I mean I feel
like we should we should rush that you
know you have another octane Pat or no
yes I think they're up here yeah they
are I feel like we can third party is a
third party I don't want to because
honestly they're probably gonna push
down towards us anyways and we'll have
more cover here from that squad on the
cliff much rather defend here they're
probably gonna be dropping down here I
don't want to fire to give away a
position if it's not a Craver patch
sizes six gigs took about mm-hmm I don't
know 3035 minutes or so yeah mine
without putting my ps4 on rest my wood
yeah go out there
out there a spot just got hit with
crypto old okay let's just wait a cell
for a second okay let's see you let's
wait let me see what the next ring is
gonna be able for you make a big
decision
exactly I think I gotta write the portal
2 there's if lines everywhere yeah took
a spiderweb here I don't think I seen
anybody on that cliff anywhere they
might have abandoned ship three
gigabytes oh I thought I was checking on
PS I don't know if that's Xbox or
different consoles with ps4 I thought it
was six
getting restless but at the same
uselessly throw myself to the wolves
squads left yeah they're like all
shooting each other but nobody's really
going down and we are in a pretty good
spot allowed like a care package landing
right next to us to their giant betas uh
yeah oh man it's so campy I know driving
me crazy okay I don't want to be like
the last game where I was so impatient I
just busted the door down to my death
there are people in the caves sort of
pinched right now yes but I feel like we
might have company coming over here
alright the ring is moved so do you want
to run or do you want to we have time we
don't have to totally run just know that
somebody was coming from that cave
behind us yeah I'm just gonna take a
look over there and see cuz there's a
wraith portal there oh there is copy
that
I want to go around the left side and
defend the ring hey portals gone so it's
been a while now it's also this care
package I feel like it's a bad idea
because they're gonna know that you are
gonna come this way and then we can go
around like maybe something good this
ring yeah Krypto
[Music]
I hear L star action well there's the 45
seconds rings close sorry help myself I
always gotta break through the bubble
shield down oh no I'm so far away I'm
coming to you they can't catch me man
this character is awesome I've been
missing out yeah octane is amazing
okay is there anyone behind this I will
kind of want to defend some battles here
before definitely here a lot of action
now good defend here
taken a look-see camping in here oh why
almost an eighth back jump I hear a
pathfinder as if oh he's on top of that
no he's on top outside but the window is
in the way so I couldn't really ping him
he just dropped down he's coming towards
us he definitely saw me I don't know
where he went though there's only three
spots left oh so that's one squad and
then
[ __ ]
shoot on the ring mm yeah that's rough I
don't know where we can go through the
bottom level yeah let's go to the bottom
level towards it Oh
ten-second shoot I dislike but I don't
know where they are shooters trapped
everywhere here I told you I should have
given you the Guardian
Oh where I wanted to go oh I almost tell
myself
okay you know what they don't see me it
should be okay right here you got a rush
after that because they're healing up
right now only the last shot actually
hit both of them unfortunately yeah the
master does 19 damage or just like a
hundred and thirty Hey we are
progressively yeah moving on up yeah all
right we're good this last one okay guys
[Laughter]
[Music]
which one are we most excited for I'm
excited for the Kings Canyon one I just
want that back yeah I think is Kenya
back so they're um I'm interested to see
how the third person one is gonna be
yeah that one too because it's like sort
of kind of vibes but not really
obviously but I don't know I like the
third person Easter Egg when that came
out
I'm also curious in general this would
be what the dummy mode is about oh yeah
I don't know if this actually BOTS that
are actually attacking you I'm not sure
like just kill as many dummies as you
can and like I've been read about it I'm
sure they have a description somewhere
mixed with players but the bots are not
just normally human enemies they're
actual legends because that dummy was
throwing a mirage yeah in the trailer
for those of you asking to see the skins
we showed off all the skins at the
beginning of the stream so feel free to
go back to the beach and check that out
if you want to see them ah where do we
want to land
wondering if there's a like the blue
area over here like what's gonna be gold
there we already have two oh yeah maybe
the armor
I'm gonna drop it this core right
I don't know if anybody land with us but
this is pretty either way oh my god that
was the worst time to only find a
creeper I'm just sad light chesses am I
the only person who can't wait for Kings
Canyon no max is definitely ready for
some kings canyon action I think since
world's edge came out and we played on
it for like a week
ever since then everyone was like I
can't wait yeah
Erik no well we are playing the gold
rush duo's game oh the new one I'm so
weary this time
yeah
this line here might be something good
this way
all right restart we'll call it we'll
call that a scratch yeah exactly
world's edge feels more flat and open
true yes it's like it's dents in certain
areas but to get to those areas there's
just a lot of good food
yeah and to me that just means oh I'm
gonna get sniped Raina ready to christen
all right noise once a get tired of
skull time be like okay well I can just
go back to no I don't want the I'm like
traumatized there's a vault Canyon let's
go way to go oh there it is
yeah the bookies are super long in the
game which one because they're probably
gonna be full the only one in the ring
is over there you want to go the other
ones by the geyser which was just on um
you know what that's probably all loaded
up and they're probably gone when I was
like okay yeah
oh there somebody here no that was the
same team no because when I was shooting
at someone the bangle or someone else
killed her like I hit a few times or did
you kill arrows me oh okay okay yeah
nevermind he just doubled Mastiff pump
doesn't me huh
I wonder why it didn't give me an assist
when you jump the bingler yeah I don't
know that's why I thought it was a
somebody else ding I literally thought
that shuffling with you and I was like
oh we're good look all right all right
that is a wrap you guys I'm gonna play
more at my desk
but yeah I hope you guys enjoyed you
know day one of the grand soiree event
there's gonna be six more game modes
aside from this one that are gonna be
released every two days it's gonna be on
a rotation so for all the apex fans out
there hop on it's live it's pretty fun
so far obviously him but that you know
it's going to be Hamill yeah
exactly weeks going on it's gonna be a
while for you guys but yeah thanks so
much for tuning in and having fun with
us catch us every weekday at 11 a.m.
Pacific time right here on the GameSpot
YouTube channel and until next time
we'll see you later see ya
you